[音楽]
みんなが知っているとおり僕はかーなーりコンビが好きです自分でご飯作ることもない
しすっごいコンビニが好きなんですけどもう今回はサークルkサンクスさんの唐揚げ
弁当が dr したという話を聞きました
こちらですねちょっとだけで見ていい4
[音楽]
良いかなあげっていうのはね味付けにすっげー時間がかかるらしいですよ家だと作って
時間がかかる作業をしっかりやって時間をかけて作ったのがこちらのカラーげ弁当の
唐揚げです
すりおろしリンゴや大代行を使われてねーな吊り降ろし人はニンニクなども使ってやっ
てとってもおいしいあ状になっているのでサークルkサンクスの新しいからあげの作り
方
奥なうんと何度ですねこっそり消えちゃったわけなのだ
新しい唐揚げ弁当の唐揚げだね大事なポイントね醤油とね
作り方なんですよああいうねーぞ企業秘密だから言えないんですけども僕こそに聞い
ちゃったわけなんて今日はちょっと僕頑張ってるんでもうサークルkサンクスの新しい
唐揚げ弁当の唐揚げをは俺のこの手で俺の力で作ってみようと
思います僕が作ったかターゲットサークル型の唐揚げどっちがないかっていうで
ゴールドの方がうまかったね
オレはーすぎよってデジセンスはサークルk サンクの金具イベント僕自身ちょっと
頑張って作ってみて比較してみようと思いますじゃあメイコが俺様
カラー下は作ったこと
ねえんだよこれでまずしっかり熱いを覚えるんですよいただきます唐揚げ
[音楽]
ブーブーんだよ作れる
turi 早速作ってみようと思いますうーんまあまあてそりゃ一瞬ヌー
肉玉ずネックを受けることが中締めを問わないならこれでや水洗いしなきゃいけないん
だっけ
そういうなんか食べ物自分が俺には判らなければないたらないからこのお皿ねやろ
こちらはちゃ
でしたございましょからのあんこあのー料理動画じゃないからとりあえずね同じことを
作ればいいんだよねはい四つ目ます技術点で疲れ版何でもいいですよ
全然楽しい芸術が凍っとりあえずこのお肉に当てつけするために正午とか持ち込める
ようなこんなに入れていいのかな
にんにく大葉で辞書今そういや
染めあっ
この lt のもしリンゴはどうする
おろしりんごからに移行する
と申します大香炉しがあった
はい完成しましたこれが唐揚げの畔付ですここでポイントなんですけど実はこの
サークル下山中のかバーガーイベント
醤油が地区によって種類が異なります東海地区関東起きた
手術区段差1分名古屋静岡だから当該地からずっとたまり醤油たまり醤油を使
ます
おおっ pop news る大きいをキュッ
ブーブー尻を出せ padi
wh
あーでもいい味だ
あああ
はっはっは
さぁさぁ
こそ覚えたよ何度しなきゃなんとかしなきゃ
ん
9分
mar
うーんマーカー三田明的にはちょっと微妙に違うかがちょっと揚げ過ぎて感じ悪いです
けどまぁ3方は基本的に同じなので味は多分同じだと思います
いただきます
うん甘いサブ木さん2唐揚げの味までと言えないんですけどもなぁ初めて射場的だと
思いましたができあがりか
本家の比較して本パッと見
同じ場内ですかねはいて上で今回サークルkサンクスさんのカラー下ペンとを自分で
唐揚げを作ってみたんですけども
me
大変だ美味しいし絵馬作ろうと思えば作れたんですけど
非常に時間がかかりました動画でなんかカットしてるんですけど実質もう1時間以上
かかってますからね
何度本かあるこの美味しい味をねサークルkサンクスのカラーげ弁当だったらすぐお店
で食べれるのでとてもオススメですそしてなんと今回このサークルk 参加さと僕の
このタイアップチックな感じなんですけども肇社長のシールがなんとなーーーんですね
サークルkサンクスの今回紹介した唐揚げ弁当に僕のシールが貼ってありますあたかも
俺が作ったようにね
なんでよかったらねサークルkサンクス握って僕のシールと唐揚げ弁当
チェックしてみてくださいかなり面倒の詳しい情報は動画の説明欄にありますよかっ
たらチェックしてみてください
本当に美味しいんで良かったらぜひ食べてみてくださいカラーイベント
革命だぜじゃあ
[音楽]
ん
me
やっぱ俺には二ツ岩
無理だ